[Applause]
happy Monday welcome back yes
yes
just let it wash over me like a warm
bath so I bet you're wondering what
became of the Ontario school teacher
with monstrous prosthetic breasts
that created the biggest uproar in
Canada since that guy killed a moose in
his kitchen with a hockey stick
and does it involve skydiving
with a self-described conservative porn
star
it does it does which means it's time
for
if it happens up there we report down
here you're watching gazumba gate Canada
2023
week 11.
[Music]
2023
we're in week 11 I believe here's what
we've been reporting to bring you up to
speed according to the Toronto Sun she
was once a he began identifying as
female last year and started wearing
massive prosthetic breasts to class the
school board still stands behind the
teacher no other choice
now there have been angry protests upset
parents and aroused and Confused babies
where you can't spell identity without
titty but we still don't know if this is
indeed a real thing a prank or a prank
gone wrong the Halton District School
Board where she teaches has come out in
support of the teachers literally in
your face fetish but how about a little
Common Sense women don't even look like
that in my dreams
so I walk you through all this for a
reason because no one else has and it's
Our obligation to provide all the
coverage that's missing in this story
this is our wheelhouse and it helps that
the teachers areolas are the size of
Wheels
but due to no actual work of my own or
anyone here for that matter we have
stumbled onto some actual real news the
shop teacher was recently pictured in
all her immense boobery skydiving
local Pilots initially reported it as a
collision of weather balloons
[Laughter]
Voodoo
hopefully he's a breast man
although that's what might some might
call the teacher too Voodoo claims he
didn't know who she was when she showed
up to jump out of the plane but he also
claimed that due to her height and
breast size taking on a tandem skydive
was a challenge it's the first time he
told a diver if the shoot doesn't open
you'll be fine if you land face down
but this raises the key question only
this show has the guts to ask do those
breasts weigh what they're supposed to
weigh or are they Hollow like that
inflatable doll I may or may not have
owned in the 90s
this is key because if you're gonna
transition and make the change more than
just an attention-seeking fetish
shouldn't it be the real weight and if
not is this trans teacher guilty of
stolen breast Valor
huh thank you
how about all the natural Buxom women
who suffer with agonizing back pain like
Dolly Parton Sofia Vergara and this guy
yeah
[Applause]
because if the Press were truly their
true weight you couldn't Skydive without
a separate parachute for each breast and
that's assuming it clears the plane's
weight restrictions for takeoff on any
normal flight you'd have to put them in
the back of the plane with a checked
baggage
so these breasts may be size triple Z
but you can guess by her easy movement
they're as empty as Joy Reed's head
people
so she's packed her own flotation
devices and if there's a water landing
she can pontoon the whole crew to safety
talk about a miracle on the Hudson
the Toronto Sun a paper says the teacher
remains on leave due to an injury not
suffered at school Rich requires her to
wear a boot on her foot so how did she
hurt her foot a reporter would ask did
she get it caught when she was putting
on her bra
maybe she fell off the stage during a
wet tarp contest
but now
she can't teach shop class she can't
teach shop class but she can skydive
so what's that tell us
that the on leave thing is as genuine as
her Dorito sized hubcaps
another word for areola
now this could be yet another twist to
the best trolling ever so you say
teachers can identify however they want
and force it on students cool Hello
Playtex I'd like to order the double Taj
Mahal
and now you're sending me home for an
injury cool I'll go skydiving with my
giant everything
this person I'd hug her if my arms were
four times longer
by the way during the dive the wig came
off quicker than Trudeau's black face
with a toilet brush
I think
you'd think a shop teacher would have
bolted it down
you know the Daily Mail which reported
on this says it's not clear what the
relationship is if there is any between
Voodoo and lamo the woman man that woman
so we expected to believe that Miss
monster boobs just randomly selected the
only conservative porn star skydiver on
Earth to pull off this stunt you know
something smells fishy for once it's not
me
but I don't care what I do care about is
how identity has embraced fetishism once
we've obliterated the binary nature of
gender any semblance of Sanity went with
it a man can identify as a cartoon
fetish scribbled on a bathroom wall in
eighth grade or in Jesse Waters case
last Tuesday
does it all the time and if you don't
abide then you're the villain even if
the truth staring back at you with shot
glass-sized nipples
gender politics is now being exposed by
its own rejection of Standards it lets
anything be a woman anything making
Womanhood meaningless because being a
woman is more than simply some guy who
gets off dressing up with planet-sized
breasts but according to the trans
movement it can be if I were a woman I'd
be pissed and who's to say I'm not
here he is let's a welcome
tonight's guest she puts the lips in
their place with a smile on her face
former whiteout strategic communications
director Mercedes
[Applause]
he's like Fonzie wears a leather jacket
and his office is in the men's room
recent editor large nicholaspy
[Applause]
she's on the no-fly list after an
exterminator sprayed her condo Fox News
contributor Kat Tim
[Applause]
oh boy and he breaks the ice by walking
across the Arctic my massive sidekick in
the nwa's world tell a little
heavyweight champion Tyrus
there's a sneaking Mercedes schlap is
like the name the sound her breasts
would make when she jumps out on the
plane they just go back and they go slap
slap slap that definitely happened when
she jumped out of the plane so okay so
look you this is the third time or so
you've been on the show we've talked
about this every time the boob gate
story comes up I am on the show
that's not true really there was there's
more times I know because I've been
there all right good well I feel
targeted and I feel like I should go up
to Canada and interview boob gate I
think you should dude do you think now
that you they've they've they've uh uh
introduced a new variable a conservative
adult film star that we're being played
well at least they're not going skinny
dipping and scuba diving that could be a
huge problem if she's trying to submerge
herself into the water what do you think
about that they could never do this well
the skinny dipping is very interesting I
could definitely around the male porn
star yeah the you know the boob gate
dude I mean this gets complicated it
does get complicated and it sounds like
what is a conservative porn star
um turtleneck when he films
and always says a prayer yes yes this
feels like a reality show waiting to
happen uh conservative porn star a male
to female trans with super triple z
cubed breasts cubed cube a little math
there for people what do you think Nick
this is your by the way this is your
first time discussing it it's okay if
you're a bit overwhelmed I am a bit
overwhelmed yes I you know with Canadian
stories if it doesn't include Gordon
Lightfoot I don't I just don't think
it's real yes I think it's made up you
better take care yeah uh well now you've
made your joke what how do you seriously
feel I it's I cannot believe it's only
Monday yeah I feel like we are so far
down the the greasy flagpole I I'm
without speech this is deeply disturbing
to me and I don't know where my life
went wrong that I'm sitting here talking
on the most popular late night show in
human history yes you have more viewers
that all the Pharaohs of Ancient Asia
and uh well you know how to get Applause
and I like that about you thank you do
you think we're being put on or do you
think yeah I think this is I think
Canada is the funniest place on Earth
and this is obviously made up okay
Tyrus welcome back thank you hope you
had a lovely holiday wonderful
this has to stop okay
what do you mean you mean me doing the
story you have to let this use the Wii a
lot and that monologue there's no way
Tyrus and Tim did not we're not asked on
this this is your secret thing and the
only way to end this is listen we'll
take the night off have her down you and
her one-on-one 60-minute interview and
get to the bottom of it because we are
fed up we are tired are you talking for
her too
he's a wee here there is a Wii here yes
which do you think you need help
because here what bothers me the most
about this and and women always seem to
be on the wrong they always get attacked
and they always there and if you say
anything about him he's like well I'm
identifying as a woman how dare you but
this is not how women are or women act
this is you're identifying with stuff
you saw on the internet with porno
fantasies and sex Edition addiction to
how women are and like it's like when
you're 13 or 14 that first video you see
and you suddenly think all women
whatever conversation you have ends with
them wanting to have sex with you yeah
and then you go out in the real world
and when you say hi they don't even say
anything to you they just keep walking
so it's real that's reality women don't
aren't like this this is not normal
behavior this is his fan Her Fantasy
trying to portray and then she wants the
same protection is that what it is to
actually be a woman and that this is not
it do you do you think that
that is really I mean I
know it's dysphoria it's this you're
trying to be a fantasy of what you think
a lot of times they're doing
impersonations they always talk about
like oh I cried five times today right
and I can't make my mind on a restaurant
those are stereotypes no you're just an
undecided person that's not what it is
to be a woman you're absolutely right
because you see the accentuation of the
of that of these kind of stereotypes and
that's what they're doing they're not
portraying what it is to be a woman it's
like they're not taking
they're living in their dysphoria
fantasy of what Womanhood is without
actually that's why they're not women in
my opinion God it's cat I go to you
dysphoria or prank well I think it's
also most people you said most women
aren't like this but also like most
trans people aren't doing no they're not
even yeah but this is the one that gets
on people in general that are not doing
this I can also point out that most shop
teachers yeah
skydivers
yeah and it's just we we've done this so
much that it's got me like I don't know
what else to say about it anymore he
needs to go to Camp which I'm about
ready to say something I thought I would
never say which is if anybody in Canada
wants to reach out to me
let me know if there's any other take
I'm missing because okay I do want to
know what injury involves wearing a foot
boot on your foot yes you can't go to
work but you can Skydive exactly because
I would like to use that the next time
we talk about this
but there will be a next time there is
going to be because you know what we're
going to get an answer to that question
Over My Dead Body okay well did I say
that
if you try to catch her yes it will be
over here
well you know what it just shows you
what a Fearless journalist I am that
against their judgment I'm with you girl
thank you
with you because you know it's either
that or covering Justin Trudeau in the
drag queen show that he showed up to I
don't know that was outrageous you just
wait until it's your eighth time because
that was
like I think she's your go-to on the
ground reporter yeah there you go you're
in all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else